when monetizing an e-commerce site there
are four main principles you should keep
in mind first let user explore before
they commit second let user purchase as
guest third make it easy to finish from
another device for use exist information
to maximize the convenience now let's go
deeper on each rule requiring a login or
account creation too early in a site
experience can be harmful to conversions
beware of making enemies at registration
gates don't require a custom account
registration upfront we understand it
getting access to the customer
information and preferences can be
integral to your website success but
don't ask for it too early in the
process you can see here on the left
side an example of the pop-up that quite
block the users from achieving her goals
however here on the right side you could
be productive and browse the site right
away offer the option to check out as a
guest and encourage registration with
tangible benefits if purchasing is
something that people can do on your
website then you want to aim for the
option to clearly enable users to check
out as guests the guests option is
universally preferred when users didn't
have an existing account at the end of
the guest checkout process you have
another opportunity to get users to
create an account and you can
communicate tangible benefits to them
for doing so for example so that they
could track their order also remember
that you don't want to nick negate the
benefits of the users purchase by having
a process that isn't smooth here all
browsers including the ability to
autocomplete forms so make sure you are
using them offer an easy way to save or
share information across devices
providing functionality to allow users
to pick up where they left off seek
opportunities to scaffold users behavior
and facilitate cross-channel conversion
through your mobile website your users
move from one device to another or
simply want to go back to where they
were on the same device this
functionality could help them a lot as
you could see here they could emulate or
share it on social networks please take
advantage of information you already
have or you third-party payment service
to make conversion as easy as possible
another useful way to streamline the
conversions experience for users is to
know and use what already exists in
terms of information that the user has
provided we also find that auto feeling
when possible was a huge benefit to
users to learn more about it just click
on this link